You know,
I don't think it will actually because
it's still a great medium,
um,
until somebody invents a cheap
electronic paper different from a
kindle,
which I still think is too complex and
too expensive for the average person.
I think there's still going to be a
place for newspaper.
But what I do think is seven day a week,
large metropolitan papers or even
smaller community papers,
it's not viable based on the revenue
that's coming in that really we have to
start.
What you'll see is news organizations
that do not identify themselves with a
form of distribution.
They're information companies,
knowledge companies that then distribute
on video.
They distribute databases or they make
available databases.
They do print additions,
they do specialty magazines,
they do whatever works for the customer
and the advertiser and whatever makes
sense financially.
And if it doesn't make sense to produce
something,
we're going to have to find financial
sense to do it.
We'll have to find a different way to do
it.
We spent an enormous amount of money
doing things that don't have much value.
Like,
why does the New York Post and the New
York Daily News,
why do they have to have separate people
producing the NBA box scores in their
newspaper?
What added value for the customer are
they producing?
Shouldn't we put our efforts where they
really provide value to the user?
Wherever the user is,
you know,
wanting to read it as kitchen table,
riding a bus,
you know,
being across halfway across the world
and wanting to know what's going on in
New York City.
W why can't we create value that way?
Um,
uh,
and I think we can because you can see
people paying for content,
but they pay for content that they
perceive provides them benefit or value,
entertainment or otherwise.
I think they'll become more of a
conversation along the line of a blog
where the reader participates and
expertise from outside starts to
moderate.
Um,
what,
what we see published.
You know,
if you look at Wikipedia,
wikipedia is a brilliant,
um,
and successful,
media initiative.
I mean they've created a new form of
encyclopedia that's living,
it's breathing and,
and the idea of a wikipedia for a
community like shouldn't the local news
organization be the in depth resource
for a community?
So if you know more about care,
for example in healthcare financing and
health care insurance,
why shouldn't you be able to work with
me as we're explaining,
you know how the Obama administration's
healthcare policies will affect
Colorado.
So I think the involving of and bringing
people in will be a really important
part of whatever anything looks like
that this interactivity,
that conversation,
that inclusiveness that it's not us
telling you,
it's actually us working with you and
trying to understand and answer your
questions.
But you,
the reader will be answering questions
as well.
I think we're in a much more
participatory world.
I actually think that's better and we
might have more information,
but we have to think of ourselves maybe
as more curators and moderators and not
just as originators.
Typically with local media companies.
They thought they had to produce
everything.
That was the only way to trust anything.
I think we're in a different era.
The Internet is self policing.
There's ways that things can be
checked for accuracy because others look
at them and comment on them.
And so,
so I'm not pessimistic about the future.
I'm actually optimistic about it.
I just recognize,
I don't know what it's gonna look like.
And the solutions are not necessarily
going to come from the traditional media
companies,
whether their scripts or hearst or
mcclatchy or the New York Times.
Well,
they at least contribute to correcting
it because let's say,
um,
let's take healthcare and we have a,
a single payer,
uh,
somebody with a single payer perspective
to health insurance.
But then we have a free market and it
aren't,
shouldn't we be the people to encourage
dialogue and create an environment for
the dialogue?
Because if it's not going to happen on
our site,
and if we're not going to be able to
inform it and answer the questions,
it's going to happen somewhere else and
we will die.
And there'll be some new form.
I mean,
I think the most conventional view of
the future is everything is going to
become much more opinionated.
You're going to sort of,
um,
go to your own affinity group and your
own,
you know,
also,
I'm a single payer person,
so I'm only going to read people who
believe that's the way the world should
look.
And I'm going to find people who think
like me and that's where I'm going to
congregate.
And that is a legitimate point of view
in that very well may be what happens.
I'm hoping,
you know,
I'm not of the mind that that's what I
want to see happen.
I would like to see a richer environment
than that where people get connected to
views other than their own.
And I think wikipedia is an example of
that where they try to,
um,
create reliable,
though it is not always reliable,
but either is the mainstream media and
this idea that,
you know,
there's been this glory days of
newspapers when everything was perfect.
Are you kidding me?
I mean,
newspapers have always tried to sell
newspapers.
There's been a,
uh,
a sensational aspect of some,
there's been different,
you know,
different things done to create customer
interest and to keep loyalty.
So,
you know,
it's not like there was this great days
of newspapers and our democracy was so
perfect and now it's terrible.
I actually think it's better now because
more people can participate and there's
a greater ability to learn more quickly.
If you think of the tools available to a
journalist today versus the tools
available even 20 years ago.
It's so incredible.
I mean,
just using search engines to find
information,
um,
using,
the fact that a journalist on the street
could have an iphone or a blackberry
where he or she's opening documents,
reading things.
I mean,
it's just,
it moves so much more quickly now that
requires a highly skilled journalists
and how are we going to pay for the
highly skilled journalists?
What are,
you know,
what kind of organization can train and
develop those people?
We don't have the answer to that
question.
Yeah.